SIGNIFICANT REPORTING BY "THE
WASHINGTON POST," THIS IS WHAT
IT SAYS, QUOTE, CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS RELATING TO NUCLEAR
WEAPONS WERE AMONG THE ITEMS FBI
AGENTS SOUGHT IN A SEARCH OF
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FLORES
DENSE ON MONDAY.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO PEOPLE
FAMILIAR WITH THE INVESTIGATION.
NOW, THIS COULD ELEVATE THE
CONCERN OVER THESE DOCUMENTS IN
AN ENORMOUS WAY.
JOINING US NOW IS "WASHINGTON
POST" INTELLIGENCE AND NATIONAL
SECURITY REPORT EER SHANE HARRI
PART OF THE TEAM THAT BROKE THIS
STORY.
EXPLAIN MORE WHAT YOU AND YOUR
TEAM FOUND HERE.
>> WELL, WHAT WE UNDERSTAND IS
THAT AMONG THESE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THAT THE FBI WAS
SEARCHING FOR ARE DOCUMENTS
RELATED TO NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
NOW, WE'RE VERY CLEAR IN THIS
STORY, WE DO NOT KNOW WHETHER
THAT RELATES TO U.S. NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, THE U.S. NUCLEAR
WEAPONS ARSENAL, OR RESEARCH, OR
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS OF OTHER COUNTRIES.
BUT WHAT WE DO UNDERSTAND IS
THAT THIS INFORMATION WHICH
WOULD IN ANY INSTANCE BE AMONG
THE MOST TIGHTLY GUARDED SECRETS
IN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT APPEARS
TO HAVE CAUSED SUFFICIENT
CONCERN THAT HELPED MOTIVATE
THIS EXTRAORDINARY SEARCH AT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S HOME.
I THINK WHAT THIS UNDERSCORES IS
THE DEGREE TO WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS AND OTHERS
IN THE GOVERNMENT WERE DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SENSITIVE
NATURE OF THE INFORMATION THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAD AT HIS PERSONAL
RESIDENCE AND WE SHOULD ALSO
EMPHASIZE THERE IS NO PLAUSIBLE
REASON THAT EXPERTS CAN POINT TO
WHY A FORMER PRESIDENT WOULD
NEED TO HAVE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION OF THAT SIGNIFICANCE
AT HIS HOME.
>> YEAH, IT SHOULD BE TIGHTLY
GUARDED.
BUT WHAT YOU AND YOUR TEAM ARE
REPORTING IS ALSO IT WASN'T
TIGHTLY GUARDED AT THE WHITE
HOUSE EITHER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE HAVE TALKED TO FORMER
OFFICIALS WHO SERVED AT SENIOR
LEVELS IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHO SAID THAT IT
WAS ROUTINE THAT HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION WAS
PASSED AROUND AND HANDLED BY
PEOPLE WHO DID NOT HAVE THE NEED
TO POSSESS IT OR TO READ IT.
PEOPLE WHO DID NOT HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE SECURITY CLEARANCES,
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T HAVE A NEED TO
KNOW, THAT AMONG THIS
INFORMATION ONE FORMER
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL TOLD US
THEY ROUTINELY SAW SIGNALS
INTELLIGENCE, THINGS LIKE
INTERCEPTED COMMUNICATIONS
POTENTIALLY OF FOREIGN LEADERS.
THAT, TOO, IS SOME OF THE MOST
CLOSELY PROTECTED AND GUARDED
INFORMATION AND THE IDEA THAT IT
WAS FLOWING AROUND FREELY AMONG
OFFICIALS WHO DIDN'T NEED TO
HAVE IT OR DIDN'T HAVE THE
PROPER ACCESS TO IT STARTS TO
FILL OUT A PICTURE OF JUST THE
KIND OF SLOPPINESS THAT MANY
FORMER OFFICIALS SAY THEY SAW IN
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WHEN IT
CAME TO HANDLING CLOSE PROTECTED
SECRETS.
>> SO, SHANE, ONE QUESTION THAT
IS BEING ASKED THIS MORNING, IF
THE FBI BELIEVED OR WERE SEEKING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AT MAR-A-LAGO,
AS YOU SAY, THAT WOULD BE SO
SERIOUS.
THE EXISTENCE OF THOSE DOCUMENTS
WOULD BE SO SERIOUS.
WHAT TOOK SO LONG?
WHEN DID THEY FIND OUT ABOUT
THESE DOCUMENTS?
WAS IT, YOU KNOW, WHEN THEY KNEW
ABOUT THE 15 BOXES MONTHS AND
MONTHS AGO, WHEN THEY SUBPOENAED
RECORD, WHY THE SEARCH WARRANT?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
WE DON'T KNOW PRECISELY WHEN
THEY LEARNED THIS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE SEQUENCE OF
EVENTS OF HOW THIS UNFOLDED, WE
KNOW THERE WAS A SUBPOENA ISSUED
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP BACK IN JUNE
WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY A REQUEST
FROM THE GOVERNMENT THAT, YOU
KNOW, SAYING WE THINK YOU HAVE
INFORMATION, WE NEED YOU TO HAND
IT BACK TO US.
IT IS A COMMAND OF SORTS.
BUT IT IS ASKING NICELY IF YOU
WANT TO THINK ABOUT IT THAT WAY.
IT APPEARS THIS SITUATION
ESCALATED, HOWEVER, WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AGAIN, FOR
REASONS WE DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND, DID NOT RETURN THE
INFORMATION THAT THE GOVERNMENT
MADE CLEAR TO HIM HE NEEDED TO
RETURN.
AND SO I THINK THAT ALSO
ELEVATED THE CONCERN AMONG LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS WHY IS HE NOT
GIVING BACK THE INFORMATION THAT
WE THINK HE HAS, THAT WE'RE
TELLING HIM HE NEEDS TO GIVE
BACK TO US, THAT IN ANY EVENT
WOULD CAUSE SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
IF SOMEONE HAD CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION IN THEIR POSSESSION
AND WAS REFUSING TO HAND IT
BACK.
WHEN IT IS THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
THE POLITICAL AND LEGAL
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT, WE'RE
SEEING THEM PLAY OUT RIGHT NOW
AND WE CAN SEE HOW
EXTRAORDINARILY THAT WOULD
COMPLICATE THE SITUATION.
>> SHANE HARRIS, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
SIGNIFICANT REPORTING THAT
REFRAMES, I THINK, HOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT THE EVENTS
OVER THE LAST WEEK.
THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING US NOW IS FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR DANIEL
GOLDMAN, NOW RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS IN NEW YORK.
DEPUTY EDITOR OF THE CITY ALISA
KATZ, CNN PRESIDENTIAL HISTORIAN
TIM NAFTALI AND CNN SENIOR
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT SARA
SIDNER.
SO MUCH HAPPENED IN THE LAST 24
HOURS, IT IS -- WHERE TO START,
RIGHT?
THERE IS JUST A BOUNTY OF NEW
INFORMATION.
LET'S START WITH WHAT WE ARE
EXPECTING TO LEARN.
MAYBE.
AT 3:00 P.M.
WHICH IS GOING TO BE THE SEARCH
WARRANT AND THE RECEIPT,
PERHAPS, ABOUT WHAT WAS TAKEN
FROM MAR-A-LAGO.
ARE YOU EXPECTING THAT WE WILL
INDEED LEARN THAT?
>> I HAVE MY SERIOUS DOUBTS.
AS YOU WILL RECALL DONALD TRUMP
SAID THROUGHOUT THE MULLER
INVESTIGATION, OH, I HAVE NO
PROBLEM TALKING TO THEM, I'M
HAPPY TO TALK TO THEM AND IT
BECAME MY LAWYERS TOLD ME I
CAN'T.
THE FACT HE SAID RELEASE THE
DOCUMENTS MEANS VERY LITTLE TO
ME AT THIS POINT.
LET'S SEE AT 3:00 P.M. WHEN
THEIR DEADLINE IS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE GOING TO AGREE.
BUT IT IS A -- THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS PUT HIM IN A REAL
PICKLE HERE BECAUSE EITHER HE
RELEASES THE DOCUMENTS, AND WE
LEARN WHAT STATUTES THEY ARE
INVESTIGATING, AND WE LEARN
BROADLY CATEGORICALLY WHAT THEY
TOOK.
SOME OF THAT WILL BE REDACTED
BECAUSE IT IS PROBABLY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
BUT WE WILL CERTAINLY LEARN THE
STATUTES AND THAT WILL TELL A
LOT ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE
INVESTIGATING.
I'M VERY EAGER TO SEE THAT.
IF THEY DECIDE TO OPPOSE THIS
MOTION TO UNSEAL, THEN CLEARLY
THEY'RE TRYING TO HIDE SOMETHING
AND IT COMPLETELY UNDERMINES HIS
ARGUMENT THAT THIS IS JUST A
POLITICAL WITCH-HUNT BECAUSE
HE'S OBVIOUSLY NOW TRYING TO
HIDE WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
DOING.
>> WHERE ARE THE PRESSURE POINTS
THIS MORNING AND WHAT QUESTIONS
DO YOU HAVE?
>> I MEAN, I THINK THE QUESTION
I HAVE IS SIMILAR TO WHAT DAN
HAS, SIMPLY, YOU KNOW, WHAT WILL
HIS LAWYERS DO, AND I THINK
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE'LL SEE WHAT
TRUMP WILL DO ONCE HE CAN SAY,
LOOK, THIS IS A WITCH-HUNT,
THEY'RE GOING AFTER ME --
>> HE'S ALREADY SAYING IT.
>> RIGHT.
BUT HE WILL BE ABLE -- BUT HE
WILL BE ABLE TO ONCE, YOU KNOW,
THE DOCUMENTS -- ONCE HIS
LAWYERS ARGUE THAT THE SEARCH
WARRANT SHOULDN'T BE RELEASED,
HE'LL BE ABLE TO SAY THEY WERE
GOING AFTER ME, THIS IS SIMPLY,
YOU KNOW, THIS --
>> A WITCH-HUNT.
>> YEAH.
THAT'S HIS DEFENSE.
>> HE'S LAYING THE GROUND WORK,
RIGHT?
WHAT HE'S SAYING IS HE'S LAYING
THE GROUND WORK TO SAY IT IS
PLANTED EVIDENCE, REINFORCING
THIS RIGHT WING TALKING POINT.
>> RIGHT.
AND THAT'S ONE THING, HE'S
SAYING IT IS ALL A SETUP.
HE'S REALLY PLAYING TO HIS BASE
HERE BY SAYING THAT, LOOK, THIS
IS -- RELEASE THEM, I HAVE
NOTHING TO HIDE, BUT THEN ONCE,
YOU KNOW, HE'S -- YOU KNOW, HE
WILL JUST CONTINUE TO SAY THIS
IS AN ATTACK ON HIM AND WE HAVE,
YOU KNOW, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
REALLY GOING, YOU KNOW, AFTER
THIS BY SUGGESTING THAT THE FBI
IS ON ATTACK AGAINST TRUMP.
>> WHAT IS THE HISTORY OF
PRESIDENTS BEING -- FORMER
PRESIDENTS BEING INVESTIGATED OR
THE FBI SEEKING CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS RELATING TO NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AT FORMER PRESIDENT'S
HOMES?
HOW DO YOU PUT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IN HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE?
>> THE HISTORY IS SIMPLE, NONE.
WHEN NIXON BOARDED THE FAMOUS
HELICOPTER WHEN HE WAVED, SORT
OF VICTORY WAVE AT THE END OF
HIS ADMINISTRATION, HE DIDN'T
PUT HIS TAPES IN THE BACK OF THE
HELICOPTER AND WHEN HE WENT TO
SAN CLEMENTE.
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT DID NOT HAVE
TO EXECUTE A SEARCH WARRANT IN
SAN CLEMENTE AND NO PRESIDENT
THEREAFTER HAS BEEN SUBJECT TO A
SEARCH WARRANT AT THEIR HOME.
THIS IS YET AGAIN ANOTHER
UNPRECEDENTED TRUMP DRAMA.
I'M THINKING A LOT ABOUT MOTIVE
RIGHT NOW AND SO I'M TRYING TO
CONTEXTUALIZE WHY HE DID IT,
SINCE, OF COURSE, HE HAS HAD
MANY OPPORTUNITIES TO RETURN
THIS MATERIAL AND HIS PEOPLE
RETURNED 15 BOXES.
LET'S NOT FORGET HE'S ALREADY
GIVEN MATERIAL THAT SHOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN IN MAR-A-LAGO BACK TO
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT.
WHY DID HE KEEP THESE DOCUMENTS?
WELL, IF INDEED HIS LAWYERS
DON'T COME OUT AND SAY, YOU
KNOW, SORRY, IT IS NOT IN HIS
INTEREST TO HAND OVER THE
INFORMATION TODAY, OR TO ALLOW
IT TO BE RELEASED, IF WE FIND
OUT THE NATURE OF THE DOCUMENTS,
WE CAN START TO THINK ABOUT HIS
MOTIVES.
NOW, I JUST WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
TO EVERYBODY UNDER THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT, AS A
FORMER PRESIDENT, HE HAS ACCESS
TO ALL HIS DOCUMENTS FOREVER.
HE JUST CAN'T CONTROL THEM.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY HAVE TO BE
IN A FACILITY, WITH PROPER
VAULT, WHICH ARE CHECKED EVERY
YEAR, AND THAT FACILITY IS IN
THE D.C. AREA.
WHY HE FELT HE NEEDED TO KEEP
SOME OF THESE MATERIALS, ALL THE
WAY DOWN IN FLORIDA, WHEN HE
COULD HAVE SENT A REPRESENTATIVE
INDEED HIMSELF, THOUGH HE WOULD
NEVER DO IT HIMSELF, NO FORMER
PRESIDENT WILL GO INTO A
NATIONAL ARCHIVES FACILITY TO
LOOK AT A DOCUMENT, BUT ANYBODY
WITH A CLEARANCE IN HIS INNER
CIRCLE COULD.
WHY DID HE FEEL HE NEEDED TO
HOLD THEM?
WERE THESE TROPHIES?
OR WERE THESE MATERIALS THAT HE
WANTED TO USE FOR OTHER PERHAPS
COMMERCIAL PURPOSES?
>> HIS SUPPORTERS,COLOR
I
-- INCLUDING EXTREMISTS ARE
FEELING VERY ANIMATED.
ANIMATED, SOME TO VIOLENCE,
PERHAPS BY WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
HAPPEN.
>> YEAH.
I WANT TO MAKE THREE POINTS HERE
JUST JUMPING OFF OF WHAT YOU
WERE SAYING.
ONE IS THAT WE HAVE TALKED TO
SPOKESPEOPLE WHO HAVE SAID THEY
WATCHED DONALD TRUMP DURING THE
TIME HE WAS PRESIDENT BE VERY
CARELESS, IF YOU WILL, WITH
DOCUMENTS.
OKAY.
SO THAT'S ONE THING, WHICH IS
EVERYONE IS CONCERNED ABOUT.
SECONDLY, THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHAT HAPPENED, HE HAS THE
DOCUMENTS.
HE CAN PUT THEM OUT RIGHT NOW.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR THE
COURT.
SO IF HE REALLY WANTS THEM OUT
THERE, HE COULD HAVE DONE IT
HIMSELF, HE COULD HAVE POSTED ON
HIS, YOU KNOW, TRUTH SOCIAL
NETWORK, AND HE COULD HAVE GONE
HAM ON WHAT WAS IN THERE AND HE
HASN'T.